I like to get close like up in your face
close
the fight against the Dakota access
pipeline is taking place on the ground
in the water and in the sky
soo-ji bees need admiring do we fly
their drones over construction sites of
the 3.8 billion dollar pipeline it's
nearly complete despite massive
opposition from the largest gathering of
tribes in history
they surveil the construction from
overhead documenting the pipeline's path
through sacred sites and providing Intel
to protesters who call themselves water
protectors they're actually now this is
how closely are to the river they're
building a barricade around their their
site Oh
so you see that you see that you see
that see they just got hit whoa we got
hit again their drones are often shot at
by police who along with private
security are a constant presence around
this portion of the eleven hundred and
seventy two miles of pipeline on a night
when police shot water protectors with
tear gas rubber bullets and water
cannons in freezing weather Myron and
his crew provided live aerial views of
the scene we have is percussion grenades
being thrown we have the police are
right down on the front there spraying
water with al rads continue to share as
fast as you can they're trying to hit me
hold on I got to get out of there yeah
they've already shot me twice go
straight up I'm doing it okay I'm
getting away but keep keep the camera on
them no matter what keep the camera on
them so this is one way they keep us
from documenting she's a drunk
this is what word we're looking at the
footage last hours after this 24 hours
looking at the footage looking at the
human rights violations looking at them
officers shooting people with their
hands up but the most disturbing thing I
think that we're witnessing is that
they're shooting them in the back as
they're running oh my name on facebook
Myron's page digital smoke signals has
become a main source of breaking news
around the node Apple fight
of signals and we're doing a non-violent
direct drone action as a non-violent
director on action issue we are aware
seems that we're doing is breaking the
rules but were not breaking the laws
we're breaking the worlds in
investigative journalism work documented
everything that reviewing by drilling
and the drilling pad we're not supposed
to or your sacred sites they have read
they have been violating tribal laws and
the Treaty of 1851 and then we take it
to an intellectual action and using
social media and put it out there in a
way of our lawyers to articulate it on a
PC so they told me to get down there
they told me to get down there is what
they said they want me to get down there
right now they're gonna take ya let's go
back our burial sites let's try to make
sure we're ready to go
[Music]
the role I play is pretty much the hides
of this guy the other day as the actions
were going on by the water there a lot
of people told me that they felt safe
that there was a I don't just hovering
above them and watching what's going on
so in a way these drones are like
protecting the camp of the people the
actions that the police officials have
been doing against this it's dangerous I
know the risks but you know that just
what fills me to keep you to do it
actually you know cuz I'm a local I've
been here I've been fighting drones
before all this blew up and I got the
first the first footage of the first
week as the front lines there and from
that on I just was just dedicated to
keep doing this today yeah well it only
got hit a couple of times but I've got
stronger tape on it now but my camera is
getting messed up Myron is now facing
charges for flying these drones
I got a charge for stalking Dakota
Hansen spy plane mercenaries out there
we're still under investigation we still
haven't got all our charges the key
point is that leveled the playing field
is that with this type of technology as
a consumer technology we followed the
rules to a tee of the North Dakota laws
the FAA regulations I knew when I got
here that I was gonna have to legally
prograde representation because I I was
prepared to be up against that what I
was witnessing was
in accuracies police fabrication the
police brutality the police the stocking
but also the militarization of untrained
officers with weapons is what we're
seeing inciting a riot came from the
police side as you guys are untrained
and they're using the indigenous people
here in all the water protectors and
supporters as their training ground
they're like all these are just a bunch
of Indians they don't have anything well
this is the second decade of the 21st
century and this is not our first ride
we've been dealing with colonisation for
five hundred years not only are we
decolonizing and reach traditional
engineer but we're protecting ourselves
as tribal government members and tribal
and members throughout Indian country so
yes we do have a technology and we've
been documenting it from day one